nous allons coulisses maintenant pourrez
découvrir les animaux les animaux qui
ont une place très importante dans les
spectacles et parades à disneyland
il symbolise bien sûr les personnages
créés par disney lui-même des animaux
qui sont chouchoutés par un personnage
un personnage que nous présente
elisabeth est gelée et gembloux faire un
câlin bien agréable pourtant ce n'est
pas un bon gros toutou c'est un loup
depuis cinq ans lionel carembault
s'occupe de bêtes sauvages mais aussi
deux chèvres dame de chevaux et de bien
d'autres espèces
il est responsable des 600 animaux des
disneyland paris
cette passion lui est venu sur le tard
parce qu'un jour sa fille a eu envie
d'un pigeon blanc
j'étais persuadé que les pigeons blancs
existait j'étais persuadé que les
voyageurs blanc bail en avait déjà
et puis je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
n'avaient pas je me suis formé dans le
conte génétique j'ai mis cinq ans pour
blanchir ou une souche de pigeons
voyageurs feuilles à blanchir arrivé à
voir ce que vous avez vu aujourd'hui des
pigeons blancs purs
400 pigeons voyageurs s'envoler d'ici
plusieurs fois par jour mais pas pour un
long voyage dans dix minutes
guidés par leur instinct ils auront
rejoint leur volière par leur part de
l'autre sujet de fierté pour lionel son
écurie de percherons la plus grande
d'europe 31 chevaux de trait à la
stature impressionnante
il participe à tour de rôle à la parade
du bossu de notre-dame suivant un emploi
du temps très strictes
c'est des chevaux qui ont aplani
exactement comme comme nous ils ont des
jours de repos par semaine y travaillent
cinq jours donc par semaine deux heures
et demie par jour pas plus trois heures
on va dire grand maximum deux mois de
vacances dans la lettre puisqu'il
repartent dans les prairies du perche
ils sont nés deux mois à venir un espèce
de roulement à 10 fait
pour gianni la chèvre d'esmeralda c'est
différent pas question de roulement ni
de remplaçante
il y a trop d'affinités entre hal et sa
maîtresse travaux cette année changement
succès donc maintenant même si comme à
quoi mme ficher en fait dans le ranch de
davy crockett les loups aussi sont comme
des petits chiens
ceux là sont tous frères et soeurs et
les premiers mois de leur vie ils les
ont passés dans la maison de lionel un
famille avec ses enfants
mais attention ça reste du voile ou un
comportement d'animal sauvage sais pas
c'est pas c'est pas le petit caniche qui
vit sur une banquette ou sur la moquette
il restera de toute façon dans ses gènes
et il faut qu'il réceptionne et moi un
loup donc il faut avoir un comportement
vigilant avec avec 600 animaux à charge
lionel prend peu de vacances ce n'est
pas comme les rênes 11 mois de congé
pour eux ils ne travaillent qu'en
décembre pour promener le père noël vue